pionnier son vivant et se porte très
bien
pierre saba il a été décoré hier par le
président mitterrand nous parlons il ya
un instant de chacune joubert qui est
quelque part dans cette maison pas loin
de nous et nous recevons anker cerné
alors quand on dit pionniers vous
éprouvez un sentiment de fierté ou
prenez un coup de vieux non ça me fait
rire parce que j'ai l'impression d'être
dans un album de lucky luke est d'aller
défricher le cloud man français la gombe
h et non autant que je travaille moi
tout va bien ce qui serait plus rentable
et que j'ai plus l'occasion de
travailler depuis jamais venir reconnu
alger ou au beach où est-ce que c'est
dans ce métier comme dans d'autres je
veux parler des artistes qui fréquenta
scène on a du mal à décrocher
bien sûr du mans parce que notre raison
notre double raison de vivre c'est
l'amour et l'amour du métier alors il
faut que les deux choses
de l'autre côté ça va très bien est-ce
que vous soupçonniez l'importance que la
télévision prendrait à l'époque avec
tous vos camarades n'ont absolument on
pensait pas du tout à ça si on s'était
posé la question on aurait certainement
prévu des développements considérables
on aurait pensé que ça allait faire
comme la radio mais on pensait pas sa
williams parce que on était trop peureux
de s'amuser à faire de la télévision
nous faisons des métiers de plaisir on
cherche à faire plaisir aux personnes
qui nous regardent
il faut qu'on en prenne nous-mêmes et la
petite équipe du journal télévisé qui
travaillent dans des conditions censées
songez que de 49 à 54
on n'avait que des caméra 16 mm muette
d'amateurs on n'a jamais enregistré une
déclaration ministérielle
mais alors qu'ils étaient ces gens ces
jeunes gens dont vous parlez dont vous
faisiez partie qui se lancer dans la
télévision c'étaient des déçus du cinéma
ya eu de dieu de tout ça bat venait de
la radio il a fondé journal télévisé
avec des gens qui venaient de la radio
mois il se trouve que j'avais fait lydec
et puis que j'étais passé par la radio
ou club décès que du mayet
m'avait entraîné dans la bande de sa
vague de sa bague de m'a pris quand j'ai
commencé je l'utilisé je jouais en même
temps à saint germain des prés oui
j'étais en même temps comédiens voyez
que on venait d'un peu partout et il ya
eu certainement du cinéma il ya eu des
parce que en 1900 les années 50
entraînant cinéma était très difficile
au moins aussi difficiles je peux
changer et il ya certainement des tas de
jeunes gens qui ont fait leur carrière à
la télévision
prenez marcel bluwal il aurait elle un
grand réalisateur de cinéma
il s'est engagé dans la télévision il
fait merveilleusement c'est curieux
parce que vous le souhaitiez il ya un
instant à l'époque on était multi cartes
jaunes dira pas que vous étiez comédiens
mais aussi une verrière et lydec l'école
de cinéma et puis vous avez fait ni trop
bas niveaux aussi bien sûr qu'on avait
allaité au journal pendant cinq ans mais
je crois que dans nos métiers il faut
absolument être multi produits que vous
dis dans les écrans d'ici mais bien un
outil produit c'est grey s'est alors en
cinquante ans on a fait le bon que nous
savons tous est ce que vous pensez dans
les 50 années qui viennent nous ferons à
un bon encore plus important où ça va se
calmer un peu maintenant on a fait
l'essentiel sur le plan de sur le plan
de l'achat des récepteurs ça va se
calmer parce qu'actuellement
kobe est il de récepteurs il ya près de
cinq millions de récepteurs je croyais à
18 à 20 millions elle a pratiquement un
par foyer en france en acheter un
deuxième pour mettre dans la chambre des
enfants
mais ce qui va ce bouleversé se
développer c'est l'éclosion de toutes
les chaînes de télévision moi ce que
j'ai envie de plus en ce moment c'est
les gens qui vont avoir l'occasion de
faire une nouvelle chaîne de télévision
d'inventer des horaires de programmes
complètement différent non il ya tout
tout un boulot à faire ce que je
souhaite simplement c'est que en se
multipliant elle ne s'investissent pas
trop très bien merci bien vous ne partez
pas on retrouve tous bien là il fait
chaud il fait bon la lumière vous
connaissez un peu la mise en main voilà
je vous êtes ici chez vous la météo
maintenant c'est avec monsieur chauffour
est précisément figurez vous que les
températures montent enfin il fait bon
quoi absolument et puis hein
et bien une nouvelle victoire puisque
après avoir battu l'équipe italienne les
français viennent de battre l'équipe
britannique donc ce qui apprend leur
position ils sont troisièmes je vous le
rappelle au classement provisoire de
cette très belle compétition dont nous
vous reparlerons
voilà maintenant ce n'est plus le
pionnier dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure mais le scénariste de cinéma
n'ont pas le metteur en scène car vous
êtes aussi metteur en scène de cinéma
cette fois vous dites dans les
casquettes ça tourne sur m mais plus
rapide avance a fait tomber les ménages
risquent plus grand chose alors
l'important disait prévert et de ne pas
être chauve à l'intérieur de la tête
vaslui s'irrite quand il parlait parce
que cet homme n'a été croiseur alors
astérix chez les bretons c'est le
nouveau dessin animé
issu de de l'idée du talent de goscinny
uderzo deux amis il faut réécrire
l'album pour faire un film où c'est à
dire que il faut en faisant l'adaptation
il faut essayer de donner un petit peu
de dynamisme ou scène parce que le la
pâte
la patte du dessinateur la pâte d'uderzo
donne un mouvement à la page bon et
l'esprit de goscinny donne du mouvement
humoristico chose mais il faut que tout
cela se rétablisse un peu dans la
dynamique du cinéma qui n'est pas
exactement la même et surtout dans un
album une chance formidable c'est qu'on
peut revenir en arrière et savourer un
gag essayer de dire plaisir ou de monter
alors qu'au cinéma bhl la rule servier
sida et sa fille alors un série ce qui a
fait son succès au début c'est que ce
n'était pas seulement réservé aux
enfants aux souvenirs
on a tous feuilleter les albums
d'astérix il y avait des jeux de moore y
avait des situations des trouvailles
est ce qu'au cinéma qui est le cinéma
dessin animé c'est réservé aux petits
est-ce que vous avez gardé cette idée de
spectacle pour tout le monde il ya des
choses tout de même qu'ils sont qui
reste parce que j'ai essayé d'être très
fiers l album il ya des choses qui
restent et qui sont de la lecture au
deuxième divers
et puis
il reste de toute façon par exemple la
façon de parler des bretons c'est à dire
des grands bretons des anglais
d'ailleurs l'enregistrement est très bon
parce qu'il a été fait par de véritables
anglais à amiens qui parle pas très bien
français et qui vient de cette façon
curieuse de m les adjectifs à des places
où il devrait jamais et oui c'est vrai
qu'on oublie qu grande bretagne c'est
chez eux
et puis les personnages portent des noms
pas non plus un personnage qui aime bien
le vin rouge qui s'appelle château
petrus s'amusent les grandes personnes
donc plus que les enfants c'est vrai bon
alors nous allons voir un expert
précisément de ceux dont vous parlez à
savoir astérix chez les bretons c'est un
film que vous pourrez voir très bientôt
sur vos grands écrans
we trust sera coaché russe
après cette rude qu'en prime contre les
bretons tu vas retrouver la gaule avec
les îles lui mais là où je suis en
armorique
il ya un village de fouilles droit
devant sans doute qu'ils puissent heures
au loin on va s'amuser à leur père peur
ne prenons pas de risques et risque une
galère fortement avec autres après les
ch'ti oui mais c'est un frais les steve
plein de gaulois aaa
tu vas voir ce niveau d'hier et gaulois
commence à l'abordage qu'on va bien
s'amuser * j'appelais de romain
un peu de potion magique nous sommes
perdus ce sont les photos je t'ai parlé
j'aurais dû
voilà ça ne vient pas à ces risques dans
récré a2 c'est toujours le journal jours
et je voudrais quand même signalé et la
présence dans ce film de roger carel
c'est la voix des ruches pierre tornade
si la voie de la d'obélix d'hier m'ont
dit alors ils s'appellent c'est un
lapsus c'est dans la suze et madame j'ai
suivi cette lapsus et les astuces
répondent astiz aussi ça ça pourrait
être votre sur wii
je signale que dans le précédent il y
avait un personnage qui sape le canal +
un ami un ami bien sûr serge sauvion
c'est césar oui nicolas silberg c'est
motus il s'appelle et alors elle le
fameux anglais dont vous parlez valora
le site et pour sa famille g bus neige
ou julie thorax mais la séquence qu'on
vient de voir the literary n'avait rien
à dire
ah bon alors est-ce que ça se vend à
l'étranger cet esprit et j'allais dire
très french écoute alors ça c'est c'est
une chose qui m'émerveille depuis de
longues années parce que rené qu'il a là
ce n'est plus là et albert qui est
toujours bien présents lui ont toujours
parlé de ça il ya 180 millions
d'exemplaires d'astérix vendus dans le
monde
et quand un nouvel astérix or il en vend
ou tant en allemagne qu'en france la
finlande
ouais et à des pays où il ya le plus
d'astérix par tête d'habitant et en ce
qui concerne le cinéma par exemple le
film sort je veux pas ressasser potes
c'est pas du bon français
le film est présenté à partir
d'aujourd'hui à 14 heures au port des
pêcheurs je ne serais pas là mais quand
il va quand il va être présenté en
allemagne il va y avoir des centaines de
noms dans ces différents pays ou alors
attendez ce test une bonne colle je sais
pas très bien mais je crois qu'à celle
qui s'appelle astéries très comme tintin
parfois dans certains pays n'ont ni
queue aussi très bien alors en finlande
c'est le pays qui a le plus d'albums à
saïx par tête d'habitant bus et les
bistrots vous voyez comme voit le jeu
ressemble pas moins très bien même
culture ou sylvain roux et bien sûr
caire
ça sort aujourd'hui on vous retrouve
très bientôt sur cette dynamique
jusqu'à mes roues sur d'où il sort une
autonomie et une à nous à 2 allez allez
merci pierre de votre visite on termine
ce journal avec patricia